our mission to defend kabul airport and
evacuate people from afghanistan as
quickly and safely as possible continues
the airport remains secure
evacuation flights are steadily
increasing and we are doing everything
we can to maximize uh safe evacuations
we did pause flights earlier today
leaving kabul
why we adjusted resources and personnel
to ensure a temporary capacity issue at
one of our stopover locations although
flight operations have resumed
as of zero 300 eastern edt today this
morning and for the previous 24 hours 16
c-17s and one c-130 departed kabul
these flights contain nearly 6 000
passengers including a couple hundred
american citizens president biden in his
remarks earlier today
made a reference to having
figured what word he used but
essentially rescued 169
americans outside beyond the perimeter i
believe he said can you explain what
that was
how that happened what happened yeah uh
he's referring to a small number of uh
of people that uh
that are troops uh they were very close
to the perimeter the the the perimeter
of the uh airport
um uh very close um and in a short
amount of time with a short amount of
distance uh uh some of our troops were
able to go out there and retrieve them
and and bring them in
yeah yeah it's 169 americans or do you
know the breakdown i i don't have the
breakdown of the uh of everybody